joining us now u.s surgeon general dr
jerome
adams dr adams thanks for being here
thank you for having me brett and thank
you to the american people who kept it
small and smart this thanksgiving
millions of people
did the right thing and for those who
did travel
and those who did attend large
gatherings we want you to know it's not
too late to take measures to slow the
spread of this virus you can still
isolate you can still get tested in
three to five days
you can still take measures that have
been proven to help us prevent
cases hospitalizations and deaths well
speaking of that new cases
friday surpassed 205 000 and that was
breaking a record set the week before
hospitalizations were at record levels
in the number of states including oregon
washington
indiana and pennsylvania so i guess the
question is is this what
a dark winter looks like or do you
forecast that this is going to get worse
in coming weeks
well i want to be straight with the
american people it's going to get worse
over the next
several weeks but the actions that we
take in the next several days
will determine how bad it is or whether
or not we continue to flatten our curve
and right before thanksgiving
we actually saw cases start to plateau
in many states
that have been aggressively mitigating
and as i mentioned there are steps you
can take
right now but i also want people to know
there's hope
we are mere weeks away from starting to
vaccinate the vulnerable
and we can significantly protect people
who are at risk for this virus
so hang on just a little bit longer
understand that the science out there
has never been stronger to support the
wearing of masks
you shouldn't have to have a mandate to
do the right thing to protect your
neighbor
to keep schools open make sure you're
watching your distance and make sure
again if you've been in a gathering of
more than 10 people without your mask on
over the last several days please get
tested in the next three to five days
i want to talk about the vaccines the
therapeutics in just a second but what
do you think
looking back now was the biggest mistake
the administration
health experts made since this pandemic
started
well that is a great question and uh
there are
many different things that we could have
done differently
this virus has been challenging uh i
wish
that uh that again this hadn't been
superimposed on top of
an election i wish that we'd been able
to come together
as a nation and really talk about the
science instead of the politics and
that's
on all sides that's all around but what
i want people to know is moving forward
again the science is been it has never
been stronger in terms of what
we can do simple powerful measures and
wearing a mask is an instrument of
freedom
it actually will let my kids go to
school it will protect my mother and you
and i talked about this
before the interview my mother's in the
hospital right now
i want people to understand that if
cases and hospitalizations
continue to go up not only will it hurt
our ability to care for covet patients
but if someone's having a baby they may
not be able to get a bed if someone
is having a heart attack or a potential
stroke like my mother
they may not be able to get a bed your
actions have consequences
and if you do the right thing then it
will bridge us to a vaccine
so hopeful so hopeful that we can get to
that vaccine with as few lives lost as
possible
yeah you tweeted out last week that the
cdc and others now estimate
that 50 or even more of the infections
that are around the country are
transmitted from people who are not
exhibiting symptoms obviously that was
not what was believed at the beginning
of this pandemic absolutely and i'm so
glad you brought that up because
again mass could become politicized but
i want people to understand that in the
beginning we did not
think based on our experience with any
other respiratory virus that we would
have this high degree
of asymptomatic spread that means people
spreading it who look fine who feel fine
who don't have a fever we now know that
over 50 percent of people according to
the cdc who were spreading this virus in
the community
look and feel fine that's why we want
you to know that household gatherings
they've been super spreader events
they've been opportunities
that have led the led to viral spread
and it's why we need everyone to
continue to be cautious
that's why we need you to think about
what you did over the holidays if you
traveled
if you uh if you were in a gathering
with a mask off with people outside of
your household
you can take steps now to prevent you
being an asymptomatic spreader
and turning into community spread still
a chance
for us to flatten this curve get to a
vaccine
wouldn't you say that testing was one of
the mistakes
at the beginning and even now you do
have testing all over the country but
it's sometimes tough
i talked to many family members who were
trying to get the fast test in order to
go
feel safe at a thanksgiving dinner and
it was three to five
hours wait it was maybe you didn't get
the fast test it was two three days
hasn't that been a vulnerability in how
we as a country have dealt with this
well i certainly believe testing has
been a challenge but i want people to
know that we are now over 160 million
tests
we've tested more than anyone else in
the world i don't want to say that
that's a reason to pat us on the back
but i want people to know testing is
available
and one of the things we're trying to
help people understand particularly
public health officials
is that you can use these new antigen
tests which return
term results in 15 20 minutes they are
just as effective at practically
understanding
who can spread the virus as the pcr test
and so uh we want them to aggressively
use these tests
so that people can get a quick answer
and they know whether or not to isolate
or to quarantine
all right you talked about the vaccines
tell people where
the optimism the reality is
as far as timing and when the average
american
could get a vaccine i
personally am incredibly optimistic
december 10th
is when pfizer will be submitting its
eua that's the plan uh december 18th is
when moderna is scheduled to submit its
eua that's the plan for moderna
and within 24 to 48 hours after
submitting their eua
we from a federal perspective have
promised and have set everything up so
that we can quickly review those euas
and hopefully start sending out vaccines
again within 24 to 48 hours our plan is
to start by protecting the vulnerable
older people
particularly in long-term care
facilities we want to immunize for
impact with the recognition that we'll
have 40 million doses of vaccine by the
end of this year
but that won't be enough for the whole
country if you're part of the public i
want you to understand
it'll probably be in the first quarter
beginning of second quarter next year
before you can get
a vaccine but you can go to
coronaviruspreventionnetwork.org
sign up for a study and you could be you
could get a vaccine
in just a few days to weeks if you sign
up for a study
and understand that again our strategy
that we're telling governors and states
is to think about the vulnerable if we
protect them then we can slow the spread
of this disease
and lower loss of life until everyone
can get a vaccine again
in the first quarter into the second
quarter next year
and if the fda moves forward with
authorization
people should be comfortable
that it's safe well let me be clear
i have been working with all of these
companies
i've been following along closely i'm a
doctor
and when they tell me i can get a
vaccine i will be
first in line to get a vaccine because
that's how safe
i think this vaccine will be i want
people to understand safety has not been
compromised
efficacy has not been compromised what
we've done
is is really thrown a lot of money at
this problem
to to lower the risk for companies and
we've moved them to the front of the
line
in terms of evaluation so their
applications are sitting on a desk
we decrease the amount of of uh time
that that is wasted in the process
without compromising safety or review
or efficacy and at 90 to 95 percent safe
uh or 90 to 95 efficacy what i would
hate
is if we had a vaccine that could in
this pandemic and people actually
didn't get it wouldn't in this pandemic
this vaccine
will have more people who've uh who have
been tested
than any other vaccine in history at the
point of authorization about 5 000
people are normally enrolled in vaccine
trials
these trials have 30 to 60 000 people so
i feel confident it's safe
i will get a vaccine when they tell me i
can get a vaccine
dr adams i want to leave with this this
was an image that went viral
in recent days and it's very powerful
it's a an icu doctor embracing a covet
19 patient
on thanksgiving day this was from
houston dr
joseph varan a doctor on his 252nd
straight day of work
at united memorial medical center in
houston and you can see it's a powerful
image
there are thousands of doctors and
nurses out there like dr varan
on the front lines in this pandemic and
they as you've talked about are really
the true heroes
throughout all this time exactly and i
want to thank dr
christine kaminskis who's actually the
resident physician who's taking care of
my mother in the hospital right now she
called me right before i went on the air
to tell me that my mother was doing okay
doctors nurses
they need you the american people to
take small
simple measures that will protect them
and get us
to a vaccine and i also know you've got
the new jersey governor coming on
please tell him i said thank you his
wife and i have been working on maternal
health
another thing that we've seen people
really not pay attention to during this
pandemic
700 women die during the time of child
around the time of childbirth every year
two thirds are preventable and we'll be
having a call to action coming out in
the next few days
so remember this pandemic is affecting
us in many different ways
but our frontline workers really need us
to do our part
well dr adams we appreciate your time
thank you for that time during these
busy days and best of luck with your
family
thank you